let's jump into this next story and it's
uh it's kind of changing the subject but
it goes in line with what we were
talking about we have this from
timcast.com prageru personality details
YouTube kids promoting lgbtq content
these videos are not child friendly and
YouTube is pushing them to indoctrinate
kids and it's worse than that this is
Aldo uh butazoni YouTube kids is
grooming children with lgbtq propaganda
although I think you actually need you
you buried the lead here and I mean
there's a lot to respect the real
concern is that at a certain point he so
what Aldo says is he signed up an
account made for 9 to 12 year olds and
then one of the First videos that pops
up recommends a kid meets gender
non-conforming person
I I'm not as concerned with just that
the issue is when it gets into the ideas
of consent and they're telling children
about consent and they start talking
about here we go consent is giving
permission to someone or something
why are they giving 9 and 12 year olds
consent lessons in a sexual context this
is what's alarming about what YouTube
kids is doing so you think it's just in
the schools and Ronda Santos has his
plan to get rid of diversity equity and
inclusion but everybody in this is is
five steps behind what's actually been
going on and going back to Elsa gate
people have been giving their kids
YouTube their kids are then they're like
YouTube kids it's good for you and then
you get some adult in a sexualized
context like drag saying let's talk
about what it means to consent and then
in this thread I think it's in this
thread you have billboard Chris we've
been on the show a guy telling him that
their goal is to decouple age and
consent quite literally saying he wants
12 year olds to be able to consent with
adults this is what they're pushing on
kids I'm not surprised by it but it's
got to be Insidious it can't be overt
they can't come out right now and just
say it it's got to be a slow creeping
malevolent force that goes under their
radar so when Mom and Dad are busy with
work and they hand the iPad to the kid
and sign up for YouTube kids because
YouTube kids is safe what does YouTube
kids say come here little boy come into
a sexualized context where we can tell
you about consent that's exactly what
they're doing the internet and like
television is like inviting a stranger
into your home to babysit your children
like if you wouldn't pick some random
person off the street you cannot trust
anything that comes from the internet
cable TV like it is written by someone
you don't know for a company that you
don't know what their values are like
even if you pick one video the YouTube
algorithm immediately serves up another
video like there's no way for you to
know for sure what's going to happen and
that's why again I can't help but think
it's like inviting just a random person
you met at the grocery store to come
watch your kids for two hours and I get
it like it's hard to be a parent you've
got a lot of stuff going on sometimes
you need a break you need to like have a
way to engage your children that you
don't need to eat their present for but
like whatever TV is not it sir what if I
told you that YouTube kids app was
promoting child strippers to your nine
to 12 year olds well that's in the
thread meet Desmond is amazing now of
course his family is quite litigious but
there's a video of him dancing on stage
for money at an adult gay bar that is
the same thing as Go-Go dancing
why is a child doing this and why are
they promoting this to other children
well I'm degradation of society to take
well that's for that's for sure is that
people are over overly sexualized
children will become overly sexualized
adults and think it's normal or okay out
of their own guilt like hey it's not so
bad what happened to me so you know it's
just looking so bad terrifying and sad
yeah it really is cycle of abuse but
it's crazy because it also plays into
what we've been talking about about the
erosion of community again when people
are so into sex when they're so into
themselves and their own genders like
they're not paying attention to what's
going on they don't know about the local
school Border City elections they don't
know about any of this stuff all they
know is just you know it's about my
sexual identity my proclivities you know
indulging myself Nothing Else Matters
outside of just treating yourself in it
and it just it takes your eyes down you
know basically and so it's uh you know
everything in life can be like into
sports so basically what typically
happens in football you know normally
quarterback he gets the ball he's
looking up at the field he's trying to
find a receiver to throw the ball to so
he's got to be aware but then pass rush
comes you know they start throwing stuff
in your face he takes his eyes down he
can't throw the ball he can't pay
attention you suddenly stopped the game
from progressing he can no longer
progress the ball and that's what's
happening with Society we've taken our
eyes off of the prize which is advancing
Humanity technology everything else you
know creating families and now we put it
down on our genitals quite literally
looking up at the stars I think about
sending probes to Alpha Centauri it'll
take like 80 years for a probe to get
there can you imagine if we do that
today in 80 years we will have probes in
Alpha Centauri centers yeah that's what
I read anyway a couple weeks ago that
sounds like really fast yeah it sounds
super fast like within a lifetime I'm
going double check it but this was like
this is stuff we should be focusing on
aliens are watching and just going like
you know they had a lot going for him
when they went to that Moon and now I
don't know what they're like when you're
calling it might be a threat but not So
Much Anymore some rich alien oligarch
just lost all of his bit on like this
interdimensional betting app and he's
like God dang it Humanity you screwed
the pooch but it reminds you the
expression like uh you can't see beyond
on the nose on your face right like if
you can't stop but think about like your
own identity and your own sexual
pleasure and we're introducing that
earlier and earlier like how can you
expect anyone to spend time thinking
about like
the society around them or moral
philosophy or science or anything else
like everything is about the internal
and I think it's good to be in touch
with your emotions but you can't be so
dominated by your like personal
consuming thoughts that you are uh
devoid divorced from the world around
you but wait there's more because we got
to put a neat little bow on this this
Tides into big Pharma because now when
you get all these kids exploring all of
these alternative sexualities now you
got the cisgender the trans pipeline so
they can now suddenly if they want to
explore let's get some Peabody blockers
let's get some gender affirming care the
next thing you know again that's where
social media comes in you know we're
right here at the whole dead internet
Theory they start getting engagement
from other people in that Community they
start flooding them and love bombing
them and so now they get addicted to
that they make you know they take it
further boom now you're done fully trans
the kid from YouTube kids and you know
that's that's omitting a lot of steps
but it's basically how it happens let's
talk about that internet Theory right if
uh if people aren't on the Internet it's
all Bots then where are the people are
they just not using the internet never
did man they're testing grass touching
all kinds of grass I think there are
tons of people who are not as gauge like
we talk about this a little bit but like
for your job for all of us like being
connected to the internet being on
Twitter stuff like that like it is part
of a professional Hazard like you need
to have the information but if you are
like an electrician who gets up really
early and works on jobs and comes back
and you hang out with your family like
you don't really have the time to just
scroll on your phone endlessly and keep
up with who's mad at who on Twitter I
mean I think that there's just a life
outside the other part is like some
people actively choose not to be online
right they choose not to have
televisions in their home they choose
not to sign their kids up for you know
Instagram or whatever else like they you
can be disengaged and you've talked
about this a little bit and like there
are alternative platforms right like I
know some parents who want to share kids
of photos of their kids but out of
privacy concerns they use they don't use
Facebook they use something more private
like there are people who don't rely on
the rest of the world for entertainment
and for us professional content and I
think that's healthier it's just hard
because I mean all of us need it like
this is our job yeah I think about what
if the power went out that crosses my
mind at least every week I'm like what
would my life become if we had no
electricity I mean part of me is just
like secretly in the back of my mind
saying like please do it do it yes yes
because I got a van that can generate
its own power and I'll be down by that
River Just Fishing yeah
back and just kicking the feet some
straw in the mouth and just cast a line
and forget about all well I think of
like all the reporters who like had to
go sit in really boring Town Hall
meetings to like get the information
then they had to call people on the
phone and talk to them constantly like
journalists still do that from time to
time but like we are used to getting
things much faster because we have the
internet nowadays they just read tweets
and report on tweets like literally MSN
journalists I don't know what they do
all they do is literally just write
articles based on what oh this world
reacts to this this world reacts then
they just oh really tweet Jim how many
times some news outlets picked up one of
my fake tweets and ran it as fact no for
real like I there's just uh how about
when I said the queen should be
impeached so I can't remember exactly
what happened but I said impeach Queen
Elizabeth and then m-e-a-w.com wrote an
article saying you know podcaster Tim
Poole calls for you know Queen Elizabeth
to be impeached and I was just like holy
crap I when that started it was
hilarious the indication of the
rupturing of that form of media is when
they just started quoting Twitter yeah
it was like 2013. imagine this
journalists like from The New York Times
walking into the middle of you know the
Lower East Side and there's a guy
outside just like rocking back and forth
oh impeach Queen Elizabeth impeach sir
what was your name what was your name
Bill Smith let's run it and then it goes
back to their time and says front page
Bill Smith calls for impeachment of
Queen Elizabeth and then they're like
hey look he's a nobody but people are
going to see the story and they're going
to be like wow and P I wonder who this
guy is yeah that's what they're doing
Bill Smith I hate that guy God darn it
oh God it's so funny though because yeah
you you sort of think about this and
then this goes into AI like AI is
literally getting all the data off of
all the crazy stuff that gets all the
clicks and then it just incentivizes
people to write even crazier articles
which causes people to tweet crazier
stuff bro and then people get in trouble
for like interacting the streets too
like we'd be on we've moved Beyond just
like people writing stuff like it's like
oh Ian Crossman Crossing like the
impeached Queen Elizabeth tweet so he is
supportive of this movement like it's
like you know what I mean it just
becomes this sort of hysterical culture
off of something you wrote as a joke or
maybe you feel that way maybe you can't
impeach the queen I know it's ridiculous
there have been several times where I've
tweeted something that is intended to to
make neither point so it's like a meant
to highlight just the circumstance like
I called the MSNBC Yasmin vesuvian story
about how she got the cold and got
myocarditis and I said I called it
anti-vaxx propaganda because what she
had a cold for three months clearly they
were making a segment that was going to
trigger anti-vaxxers and make them think
this was like I'm not and I tend to make
any point other than this is the
narrative this is like
just highlighting this thing basically
but they will take it and be like Tim
Poole is dead serious and thinks MSNBC
does these things and I'm like and part
of their story is also look how many
people are listening to person to this
guy look how many people are listening
to that they don't point it out they're
not like it got 80 000 repeats but they
don't really report on stuff until it
gets to a certain level of people
listening and then they're like we have
to take it seriously but we don't really
know how to accelerate writing a story
about it at this point at this point
guys we just accelerated as fast as we
can man just the hot takes they write
hot stuff people go mad people go insane
in the loop and psychology continues
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time